rip it a little bit like this and as we
go and as I speak to you talking back
and say hello hello today we're at mr.
fries man in Gardena California and we
are trying some extreme ass fries like
with Barbara you know if people come in
and come and get food we want to make
you feel compliment your flat home reach
at the door actually how your day is
going how's everything are y'all doing
there look we gonna start here got the
fries low season cheese steak bacon a
little over easy egg sauce and some of
my hello hot sauce okay let me know what
you think oh my god what do you think so
on
that's so good hello so I'm talking
about the egg complements that was
really good yeah that egg makes it kind
of more subtle actually made me just
really push forward with the whole idea
with my fiancee she got laid off on
Christmas Eve so which got laid off I'm
sorry you don't have to work I'm gonna
take care of this we're gonna be good
down to my last four hundred dollars in
my bank account I said I got idea for
sale was that So Hee Sun and fries came
with that after that made with lemon
garlic shrimp shrimp scampi buffalo
chicken barbecue bacon ranch chicken you
know the barbecue chicken pizza fries
like the piece of a bj so I came up with
those she took it pretty for me post an
Instagram
promote it the whole January after that
rest was history kept on pushing it's
kept long Bryden around 200 serious
calamari yep shrimp yep
bacon yep and it kind of looks like
there's a little lemon garlic sauce so
let me know again I'm gonna eat so I'm a
big on seafood Paul yeah so you very
much singular about it and this is some
good people prized are extremely subtle
so you can't really taste them you kind
of forget that they're even there
until you see them the seafood was good
which is great it's just it's just a
plus that you have a good seafood with
fries like why don't any went into this
before the addition of bacon - the
seafood gives it a crunch and unlike a
smoky just that bacon taste added to it
is so great with this last year we had a
Thanksgiving that came with the
Thanksgiving thing we got a lot of
turkeys made a few buddies of mine did a
Christmas Drive - gave our toys to kids
trying to do a lot of like positive
things help community out on all type of
stuff you know just keep it
family-oriented keep our family friends
make sure everybody's on a straight path
welcome back again and again I got that
four-way for y'all yeah so look what we
got back here snow crab no no crap
barbecue bacon ranch chicken oh my gosh
like the nacho cheese steak fries and
buffalo chicken back here this one no
I'll tell you see that is crazy fact
that you can get fries or different
types of wait until one container we
don't just burn this this would be like
so perfect if you guys if you're having
like friends getting together or if like
you and four friends are drunk and you
guys want to go home and you guys want
to get drunk food you can get that and
call it a day and you guys have a good
variety of variety of things all of them
have their their purpose of fulfillment
for whoever whatever tastes you kinda
have they have something that can kind
of satisfy that so I think it's really
cool
technocratic love it and I'm there I was
absolutely you should come too
[Music]